Put yourself in the shoes of a burglar...
...so you can anticipate where they'd look for your valuables.
You will need...
...a home safe and an empty cereal box.
Step one : Understand that the burglar has two goals,...
...to find your valuables and to get in and out of your house as fast as possible.
Step two : Leave a small amount of cash in an obvious spot...
...so burglars think they've found all the cash in your house...
...and won't bother looking for more.
Step three : Spread out your valuables and money.
Hide some in messy areas that would take a burglar too long to go through,...
...such as a child's room, basement, or garage.
Don't hide valuables in obvious places like drawers or purses.
Step four : Make a diversion box with an ordinary item, such as a cereal box.
Store valuables in the box.
Step five : Store extra valuable items in a home safe bolted to the floor.
Step six : Keep track of the valuables in your house in case you are the victim of burglary.
But hopefully, you'll outsmart the burglar by staying one step ahead of them.
Did you know?
From 1998 to 2007, property crime in the US declined 10%.